hello I'm Carlo and I'm Gabrielle and
we're honor Ateneo study - we are here
to discover the beautiful city of cheer
hey but we're not alone
we're their classmates
Marone where architecture is very very
nice the dark stones are very
interesting it's so different from what
I've seen before in the Philippines
it's very big it's bigger than our
churches in vanilla and it's right
beside the that there's two churches
here so the cathedral and then another
church right there so it's very unique
one to z
we try not step on the canals because
there's this rumor if a mystic on the
canals who rain yesterday our friend
wrong has stepped on the canal of Saint
Peter and it rained because of him
I notice that all these sculptures they
don't have noses it's very strange
this is the biggest gesture I've ever
seen so much gold coins I wish I had
this money there is so much gold
it says here that it's 18 point five
kilograms heavy and it's very heavy I
can't even lift it
that's why
we don't have these kinds of flowers in
the Philippines but they are very
beautiful and the best part about this
is that
we're on our tour boat and the Mosel
River and then it's gonna cruise
downstream and upstream
so that's our danger here and as you can
see we all had a great time